my name is moonlit I'm a partner develop
manager Google Play specialising games
I've been with Google for three years
before Google I was a Revenue p.m. at a
mobile gaming company in Cusco Lee at
the time and also for the three years
about working with Google one of the
most common questions is how do we
monetize in the world of games the
service but before I jump in I want to
understand you guys better show of hands
how many of you have premium games only
well surprising how many of you have IEP
games in that purchase games great
awesome so here's the deal
I'm not going to say that everything
I'll tell you today is new but my take
away my hope for you to take away from
my talk is to think about revenue
diversification think about different
ways to monetize think about different
ways to design your game to monetize so
I'll talk about three different things
in the next 30 minutes first it's about
LTV what it is and why it's important
second I'll share a list of common
in-game monetization designs for game as
a service free to play games with in-app
purchases and last I'll end with some
tips about earning in the global market
because as you launch your game with
Google Play it is by default a global
business alright first LTV LTV or
lifetime value remember the last time
you walk into a video game store can
somebody tell me what is the LTV if a
customer in the traditional world of
console pc gaming one game just one game
what's the LTV of one game any guesses
what's the lifetime value of a customer
if you buy a game it's just a
price the game right in this olive oil
it's simple you make a game you sell it
transactions done you make some money
and you move on but in the world of
games as a service it's a little bit
more complex your game now your revenue
now is the sum of many micro
transactions therefore your players
lifetime value is not heavily affected
by two things lifetime value time and
value what is time time is engagement so
we're going to look into both of these
very important elements LTV I'm not
going to dive into how the calculator
it's a whole different science but we're
going to talk about very high level how
do you increase LTV by increasing an
understanding engagement and a value for
engage and what the question is how do
we track engagement what does it mean a
Google Play we look at two buckets of
things the first one is hard retention
within the percentage of user who come
back to your game the next day a month
later a week later and I'll share with
you what are some benchmarks by category
the second one is engagement profile
first is frequency session and frequency
and session time which measures how much
time a player spends in your game and
how often they play the second while we
call the stickiness factor it's pretty
common standardized industry term which
is tau divided by Mau or how likely you
are to convert a very infrequent player
into a more committed one so of the
three retention is king more so
long-term retention is all really care
about so on the right hand side you can
see by broad-stroke the days 30
retention number of core McCrory very
very broad stroke high-level different
genres most of the games we see fall in
the grassy green area
you want to aspire to be in the forest
green on top as I mentioned we care
about long-term retention because the
more time a players spend in your game
that's more opportunities for you to
monetize and the more time they spend in
the game also signal that they are
committed to you and to your game so
these fans are also more likely to pay
higher to pay more on the graph on the
right hand side we plotted the top
grossing games on Google Play
this is retention over time goodbye
top 10 grossing top 100 top thousand as
you can see good retention is strictly
correlated with revenue potential as
well so my recommendation for you is to
really think about how to design your
game to create a long term experience
think about people turn why do they turn
how do you prevent churn and remember
more engagement more time spent means
more LTV now let's talk about second
element of LTV the value element we look
at churn for a lot of the players and
found that the churn between a person
who never spends in the person who
spends the very first dollar drops off
immediately any plateaus after that what
this shows me that the most important
dollar a player can spend in your game
is the very first one which is
unfortunately also the most difficult
hurdle to overcome but some of the
mechanics I'll show you later will
address this
I think Davey also mentioned this past
spending is also the best predictor of
future spending patterns again reaffirms
where that first dollar is very very
important when the person spends once
but not again actually we see a 30 to 40
percent drop-off I think 40 or 50
actually drop up between the
first purchase and second insert so if
you think about the spending behavior
somebody who buys once but not again but
continues spend time in your game
they're becoming more like an umpire to
you so you have special offers for that
first dollar conversion also have
something similar for this special
second assert conversion later down in
the game are you guys familiar with the
concept of price elasticity anybody know
what this is awesome it's just a very
fancy way of saying different
willingness to pay so let me give you
example what's your name
odd can ok how much if I want to buy
your shoes how much would you sell it
for $50 what's your name if would you
buy that for $50
would you buy $50 would you anybody on
the path for 4030
so here's idea for the exact same item
different people have different
willingness to pay and that's why
somebody else asked earlier do we need
to test different prices the answer is
yes and no would attest for so on this
graph you can see the negative
correlation between price and quantity
you also test different price points
such that the area under the curve or
price times quantity is maximized and
that's a revenue maximizing point price
point but another question is when a B
tests prices wouldn't players feel like
welcome I got this for $5 but he gets
four three so here's a trick when you
test different price points also have
different in-game items so the price per
item is fixed but you bundle eight
different items at different price
points it's a way to gauge where our
users more likely to take out the wallet
and spend even though they're buying
fundamentally different things make
sense okay so a lot of these games have
an IP store in the game where your
service different points different
prices do
scuse four different players so think
about managing this as managing a real
retail store like Whole Foods
you wanna keeping you keep your refresh
keep you fresh for you to come back
build a habit of checking it and see
what's going on so this is one of the
actually Mike's previous company
congregate game so what they did is that
they will vary the items in this in the
store based on different things time
based their different promotions based
on time of the year time of the week
progression based sometimes you offer
different things or people at different
parts a different part of the game and
also they have temporary promotions and
more permanent ones so really think
about managing it to keep it engaging
it's almost like a store in itself now
the most important question you want to
ask when you design anything with the
price tag on it is why with my players
buy this are they buying it out of
frustration
we're buying out of it because it gives
you more premia experience give them
more delight and my votes for the latter
anything with a price tag panel should
be aimed to enhance the players in-game
experience you also want to show them
why they want to buy it so it's not very
clear with the virtual goods what's the
purpose of that so a lot of people have
encouraged users to try out premium
currency or premium item as part of the
tutorial just to showcase the value
again the value of the items you're
selling another one is timing is very
important
think about why right if you have item
that offers to extend the game plate
surface it when the players the game
ends so timing the surfacing with the
players neat next I want touch on some
quick high-level lessons about live
albums you guys heard of live ops live
operations to do it well often times you
do need a dedicated team or even one
person to run it but I
to share some high-level insights and
learnings that can help you think about
increasing engagement and increasing
value again ultimately increase your LTV
so LiveOps has three interrelated
elements content event and sales and of
the three content is King it powers both
events and sales for events there are
two types of things you can run the
first one is called the core game loops
event where you have time limited goals
and achievement to encourage players to
replay part of the existing core
gameplay so for example for strategy
games to read with the pulse rates for
RPG is to replay something for puzzle
games is to increase the life so you can
change you can try different levels
again and if you have the ability to
dynamically introduce pieces and new
content we call this the dynamic content
where you introduce side missions if
there's no new content for the players
to try but again with a time-limited
fashion the second idea about sales is
that it doesn't always have to be about
IP discounts which often will inflate
you in-game economy so think about
running sales as a way to bundle your
existing IP options with something extra
in the item in the scale so for example
for strategy games sometimes they
throwing a free builder for a limited
period of time if you purchase at an IEP
and for RPG and puzzle think about
different ways you can make the content
more interesting on top of I ap discount
now I'll share with you a collection of
some of the most common in game designs
again most of these will probably very
familiar to you but my goal is to give
you some new ideas and think about
different ways to innovate starter back
somebody mentioned this earlier
it's by far the most effective way to
convert that first dollar a lot of games
offer a bundle of items at a huge
discount 40% of more the goal is to
encourage the very first by timing is
very important to the first seven days
after install is the golden period or
surface starter pack and as I mentioned
earlier about the second purchase think
about using a second purchase starter
pack if a player buy something but it
stops buying but continue to stay with
your game for a longer period of time
many developers also make it time
limited to showcase scarcity to
encourage purchase again within the
first seven days premium content David
mentioned earlier that premium content
by itself does not quite work but think
about instead of premium content as in
paid to buy to pay to create a game
period about any pieces of content in
your game can have a premium version of
it premium clothes premium Maps premium
powers so think about breaking out
different pieces of your game and a
premium level of that social spending is
when we have higher willingness to pay
we're buying item as a gift to your
friends not for yourself so this concept
also applies for mobile games as well
games with gilts or social elements
sometimes let user purchase a premium
item that will actually benefit their
friends competition is very important is
one of the drivers why people will
purchase earlier David mentioned that we
have vanity items it's most effective in
a more PvP setting it's not just so that
you can showcase unique personality and
style but he also works really really
well
if these vanity items also signal
strengths and skills so level one item
will look
very different from level 104 games with
competition as an element that's signal
that social proof is very important and
can be a driver for good monetization
design power-ups is pretty common one
mostly most often seen in casual games
this is when players are especially
stuck on certain level again your goal
is to help them spend more time in your
game in the longer period of time so
when they're stuck the best way to help
them overcome that and powerup is a way
to help them progress faster in a more
difficult way of an earlier in game
customization as mentioned earlier most
effective in PvP games but even in games
that's not strictly social people do
spend money when they think about this
have different ways of represented ID
there are styles one of the very popular
genre right now is interactive story
games you can argue is very much a
single-player experience but when I'm
faced a choice to wear something very
plain wear really customize a character
to showcase Who I am inside
that money comes not that big of a deal
anymore extent gameplay is another way
to think about monetizing this is very
often used in games that's time limited
or it's a skill based so this is also
often seen not just as IEP but also as
free worded ads since a very quick way
to extend game play game players I'm a
little bit extra to help them over push
them over that hurdle some games also
have this very direct way to pay - as a
way to shortcut leveling so instead of
grinding for months or weeks and months
today they can pays a small amount
instead to speed at a very early stage I
only recommend this if you have a lot of
content already out for the game so
think about strategy game
some pvp games where everybody's up here
I just joined the game I want to catch
up to them that is one way to do that
but if you don't have a lot of content
if you have a premium option to help
player fast-forward the game they might
run out of content and they might turn
so really think about balance the time
and a value element of your game design
now the next two designs monetization
designs are not strictly it not
purchases but it's a trend that we've
seen or picked up by game developers
somewhere around the world the first
wise designing subscription as a way to
engage the high value players so think
of subscription not as a content bundle
but as a VIP program like the airline
mileage program it's used to really
amplify the players time and value and
especially IEP spending we call these
the multiplier for IEP so this is a game
called legendary game of heroes but
network they have a VIP program that's
evergreen and everything you do in game
and gives you VIP points whether is to
complete a challenge or purchase some IP
items and that's accumulate more points
you also unlock more benefits and you
have to be a VIP a subscriber to
activate these benefits they've seen
incredible retention so actually this is
true for many other mobile game
developers who have in-game subscription
implemented they often reported a higher
retention plus a higher LTV
again remember more time spend a longer
period of time leads to higher LTV the
second one is rewarded ads for this one
to think about the trick here is think
about how to optimize it how to
incorporate in your game design so it's
more effective so the framework either
use have four different elements
the first one is placement where do you
place it the recommendation from
congregate is that the wooded ads should
be core to your game
you should be the reward itself should
be meaningful but not competing directly
with the I ap the second one is
targeting who can see it and the answer
is that everybody should have access to
what it adds but recommendation is that
user should initiate experience but
again you should test this out as David
said earlier there's no one right answer
for all the games the third one is
cadence how often should the user watch
me what it adds congregate tested many
things and found that six to eight ads
per viewer per day maximizes return and
the last one is measurement how do you
know you know what it adds is working as
intended
so they cohort they're a user base based
on these two metrics ad viewership and
frequency who's watching it and how
often are they watching it track your
core metrics the retention engagement by
a retention or by a conversion metrics I
mentioned earlier by these two cohorts
and you want to see if they behave
differently if they watch too many ads
or no answer at all alright next I'll
share some tips about going global with
Google Play we know when you launch your
game with us your game is by default
available if you make so available all
over the world and different players
besides different price points also have
their preferred way of payment credit
cards here we chat in different places
PayPal but if a Google Play we try to
find different ways to let user pay with
the form of payment where they're most
comfortable so these are some the latest
stats on where things are available in
how many countries they're available in
so we take care of the billion part so
you can focus on making the game now
when you launch your game you have the
store listing page it is the very first
thing that players will see when they
come into your
so making sure that your stole listing
page is appealing it's relevant
culturally and it's relevant in the
local language is very very important so
here are some tips about how to manage
your storefront so that a user comes in
they're more likely to install the game
I'm not going to go through each of
these you can read through it but what I
do suggest that is I use the store
listing experiments free and available
in the Google Play console the really
test what kind of icons have the highest
conversion what kind of screenshots
what kind of short description a long
description you might be surprised by
what you find
remember this graph from earlier price
elasticity is also true it change it
varies country back country as well so
what that means is for many countries
even one dollar is a little too much a
little bit too much so we have this
option for sub dollar pricing in many
many emerging markets the exchange rate
here is a little outdated but the point
here is that exchange rates fluctuates
people's willingness to pay fluctuates
so it's a lot of work for you to pay
attention to these fluctuations and
think about different ways in different
price points so Google Play console has
surprising template that you can use
will automatically update these for you
but you think about pricing emerging
markets consider lower the lowest point
of skew such that these players can
players who can't afford higher price
item can still take out their wallet and
purchase your items here's a case study
from Abby enemy's developer called dis
mob when they launched sub dollar
pricing in their game they were able to
triple triple their buyers and triple
the number of transactions so really
think about meeting your players where
their willingness to pay is
the very last thing is it's not only at
about the absolute price points but also
how the price looks matters too and
comes to conversion a lot of things in
America things ending 99 cents it's not
true in Asia now truing China not to
encourage nurturing Japan so when you
think about prices just doing the pure
conversion of the exchange rate might
make the end price look really weird for
the local user so not just convert your
prices but think about localizing
cultural izing your prices as well one
take away from my talk running a game as
a service the most important thing is
think about how to increase your players
lifetime value and the two factors that
mostly affect your total LTV time and
the value which converts to engagement
and value for engagement think about
retention think about session frequency
session time think about stickiness
factor and for value think about that
first dollar conversion and second buyer
conversion all right thank you so much